we're to go to Michelle who is in
Phoenix Arizona Michelle you're on the
Dave Ramsey show hi my questions for
Rachel and Rachel I'm really interested
in knowing more about your new book and
kind of what your message is because I
feel like you wrote that book for me
it's something I really struggle with
with in particular where houses are
concerned like my husband and I are
getting pretty close to the end of our
debt snowball and we're so excited about
it but at the same time I know we're
doing the right thing but you know I'm
surrounded by my friends that I probably
have comparable income situations to us
and they live in these gorgeous houses
and you know I'm like a decor junkie I
spend all my time on blogs looking at
pictures or pretty houses and I just I
want to know if you have any words of
advice on how to kind of keep my eye on
the prize when I'm surrounded by more
immediate one yeah no absolutely and
especially since you guys have been in a
season of sacrifice and you cut your
lifestyle sure significantly to put
money towards the debt you're probably
just like starving for a good t.j.maxx
run or something right it's like I just
wanna join so this whole comparison game
it's a hard one that's one that I feel
like everyone deals with on some level
or the other and so but that's one thing
that puts me at ease sometimes when I'm
in that battle my husband I got back
from a vacation and I remember sitting
on the couch and looking at other
people's vacations on Instagram
literally right when I walked in the
door from vacation and I already felt
myself being discontent and like you
know my vacation was already one-upped
and it was just this feeling of like oh
my gosh we could do bigger and better
why didn't we should we have you know we
could have spent more money in your in
your mind almost just goes in a tailspin
and your present joy is completely
stolen and so I would say first and
foremost that you have to put blinders
on and you have to really focus on you
guys and what you value and right now in
life you guys are so close to getting
debt-free and these short-term
sacrifices it's going to give you
long-term gain it's gonna pay off you're
going to have the ease that possibly
your friends don't have and that's one
thing we have to remember especially
when we compare our lives
to friends and family and you
on social media that we don't know the
entire picture you know we may unless
our friends share with us but we don't
know what's going on behind the scenes
sure they may work hard and make a great
income and pay for it all and that's
great
or they may have just redid a kitchen
but they took a second mortgage out on
the house and now that's stressing them
out or those car payments you know it's
a fight every month to scrape that money
together and he works crazy hours just
to keep up with the payments I mean you
just never know the side of the store
what we always see usually usually
especially on social media is just the
best of everything - highlight reel and
a lot of friends unfortunately today I
feel like we aren't in places all the
time with our relationships where we can
get on that deeper level we can know
each other that well that everyone can
sometimes puts on a facade that
everything's okay and everything's going
well where that isn't always the case
and so I would just say to paint your
reality and to put those blinders on and
say hey this is what we're focusing on
and again when you look back you're not
going to regret getting out of debt you
would regret going you know and and
spending money that that you that should
be going to debt on decor and other
things because the thing is when you are
debt-free and have been that money's
freed up you get to go decorate that
dang house in a really nice way by
saving I'm paying for and that's the
thing I want people to know is being
wise with your money and I talked about
this in the in my new book being wise if
your money doesn't mean that you can't
live a great life you can still live a
great life and do it debt-free it may
look different it may you know there may
be some sacrifices involved but over the
big scope of your life I think you guys
are on the right track Michelle you're
doing a great job and and I know it can
be tiring and be exhausting but at the
end of it having that that freedom of
having no payments not only emotionally
does that let you relax but also again
mathematically the the amount of
momentum you guys can gain to go do the
things you really want to do is going to
be there for you in your finger tips
Michelle thank you for the call thank
you mention Rachel's book I know you're
excited about it we are excited about it
and as fate would have it have a copy
right here on the desk here it is if
you're watching on the video channel the
YouTube channel there it is love your
life not there's advance reasons the
advanced readers copy says they're at
the top so I mean this is super
exclusive here uh and you can actually
pre-order the book right now release
date is Tober 3rd october 3rd but you
can actually go to rachel cruise dot-com
right now and you can actually get it
for $19.99 and when you do that you
receive $70 in free bonus items that
includes the love your life not theirs
ebook and digital audio book she just
did that by the way that was an
exhausting day when you read the book oh
gosh some people are say Alex washing
hands for days toward a bra so yeah will
you do it in just like small increments
after a while your voice gets tired no I
understand and then of course Rachael
smart conference talk that she has done
on this very topic a great talk very
very popular you'll get that as well and
in the e-book of the book that she wrote
with Dave the number one bestseller
smart money smart kids who get all that
that's about seventy dollars in value
you get that when you pre-order the book
Rachael cruise dot-com hey you guys
Rachael crews here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right it's kind of better
than the day
I'm kidding I'm kidding so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget one of
the best videos out there
you